[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous buvez assez d'eau
parce que c'est important de boire de
l'eau franchement ça c'est une chose que
je peux vous recommander sans l'ombre
d'un doute
notre cerveau nous poumons et même nos
os sont composés d'eau
c'est aussi l'eau qui maintient notre
température corporelle qui
lubrifie nos articulations qui éliminent
les toxines
Jean lol c'est la vie donc buvez de
l'eau sans même y réfléchir ça c'est une
chose que je tiens pour certaines et qui
applicable à tous les êtres humains sur
Terre sans plus de considération
personnelle
le reste des réflexions que je m'apprête
à dérouler devant vous sont
sont nettement plus subjectives disons
que il s'agit de mon interprétation
unique et personnelle d'un sujet d'une
problématique sociale qui touche
aujourd'hui une grande partie de la
population mondiale
c'est aussi un cheminement de pensée que
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir confronter
à des personnes à travers la France et
le monde
ça n'est en aucun cas une vérité absolue
mais je suis intimement persuadée que
c'est une bien meilleure approche à un
sujet qui malheureusement aujourd'hui ne
propose souvent que des murs et des
larmes
ce sujet
c'est l'addiction
OK
j'ai envie de vous poser une question
pensez-vous qu'on est tous addict à
quelque chose
peut-être
c'est dur à dire
l'addiction est habituellement
divisé en deux catégories on va dire
qu'il y a d'une part les addictions
dites classiques donc à une substance et
d'autre part les addictions plutôt un
comportement
donc la répétition d'une action d'une
boucle les deux sont caractérisés par
les effets physiologiques qui prennent
pas dans notre organisme lorsque l'on
s'y adore
et les recherches qui sont encore en
cours aujourd'hui tant de ta valider que
les effets enfin les mécanismes
intrapsychiques de la pulsion addictive
sont les mêmes
même si les seuls addictions
comportementales reconnues médicalement
en France à ce jour sont les addictions
aux jeux de hasard et d'argent et les
addictions aux jeux vidéos
la vraie difficulté de classification
réside dans ce que finalement qu'elle
soit classique ou comportementale en
fait les addictions ont toutes une base
un socle qui est commun même si après
selon ce qu'on décide d'en faire elles
peuvent avoir des effets différents sur
le long terme
la nourriture ou l'addiction alimentaire
est un parfait exemple de ce que je
viens de vous expliquer parce que
typiquement c'est le genre d'addiction
en fait qui qui mélange l'addiction à
une substance et l'addiction a un
comportement il y a d'une part
l'addiction à l'acte de manger et
d'autre part l'addiction aux effets
physiologiques ressentis de par le
processus d'ingestion et de digestion
des aliments consommés
donc
si on décide de prendre l'addiction sur
un spectre plus large
en prenant en compte évidemment les
drogues douces dures l'alcool
mais aussi le sport
le chewing-gum le shopping les jeux sur
votre smartphone l'adrénaline
l'astrologie
l'amour
je vous repose la question
qu'on est tous quelque chose
je vais affiner la question vous m'avez
devancé et vous demandez si vous êtes
addict à quelque chose
prenez le temps et
surtout la sincérité de vous poser
honnêtement la question est-ce qu'il y a
une chose que vous ne pouvez pas vous
empêcher de faire
une pensée une boucle un comportement
qui vous savez ne vous fera pas
forcément que du bien mais que malgré
toute votre bonne volonté et toute votre
lucidité vous ne pouvez juste pas vous
empêcher de faire
ne vous inquiétez pas je m'attends en
aucun cas est-ce que vous me verbaliser
la réponse non en réalité je vous pose
cette question parce qu'il y a une
nuance dans vos réponses qui
m'intéressent j'aimerais savoir si quand
vous avez répondu intérieurement à cette
question vous avez automatiquement pensé
à un exemple
ou bien est-ce que vous avez pensé à une
sensation
autrement dit vous êtes vous dit
je peux être addict aux réseaux sociaux
ou bien vous êtes vous plutôt dit j'ai
peut-être addict à la sensation que je
ressens quand je reçois des
notifications des likes et que je
scrolle sur mon téléphone pendant des
heures sans avoir de vraies buts
parce que c'est une vraie question en
fait
est-ce qu'on est addict à l'alcool où
est-ce qu'on est addict à l'ensemble de
sensations que la consommation d'alcool
nous permet de ressentir
ensemble de sensations qui nous
permettent du coup d'explorer une autre
facette de notre personnalité peut-être
un peu plus sociable un peu plus
charmeur
ou un peu plus confiant
disons que
on est addict non pas à des choses ou à
des substances mais plutôt un ensemble
de sensations qui nous permettent
finalement d'exploiter de d'aller
chercher des autres versions de
nous-mêmes des autres facettes de notre
personnalité
je vous repose la question
pensez-vous qu'on est tous addict à
quelque chose
c'est intéressant non de jouer avec les
définitions
ça amène à une autre idée
une autre question plutôt qu'est-ce qui
fait qu'on passe de l'usage à l'abus
de l'usage à la dépendance
on est tous d'accord qui a
fondamentalement rien de mauvais avec un
jeu vidéo
il y a même une équipe de chercheurs de
scientifiques allemands qui ont prouvé
que la pratique régulière d'un jeu vidéo
permettrait de maintenir même
d'augmenter la plasticité neuronale si
on soit est plutôt cool
mais
vous serez tout aussi d'accord avec moi
que de passer 12 heures par jour à jouer
à un jeu vidéo et par conséquent de
ne plus se laver de manger de manière
chaotique et de développer des insomnies
chroniques bah c'est pas terrible
c'est même plutôt mauvais même si
en soi le je ne l'ai pas
ce qui m'amène à l'idée suivante si
finalement
si finalement on n'était pas addict à
des choses mais qu'on était plutôt
addict à ce qu'elle nous permette de
ressentir si on n'était pas addict aux
jeux vidéos mais plutôt addict à la
relation qu'on entretient avec le jeu
vidéo est-ce que cette relation nous
permet de nous empêche de faire
parce que
de vous à moi pensez-vous vraiment que
l'addiction ça se limite à
la répétition de cette action et où la
consommation de cette substance
m'apporte énormément de plaisir
j'aime le plaisir
j'adore le plaisir c'est parfait je vais
écouter je vais répéter cette action
encore encore encore en
ignorant pertinemment les conséquences
négatives que je sais évidemment que ça
va avoir bien sûr sur la vie
professionnelle et personnelle et voilà
et
ça y est c'est ça
tu as dit
mais je suis vraiment persuadée que
c'est bien plus complexe que ça
parce que
si on comprend pas vraiment les choix
qu'on fait
mais pourquoi on les fait comment est-ce
qu'on peut prétendre comprendre et
contrôler son addiction
comment peut-on prétendre comprendre et
contrôler son addiction alors qu'on ne
se comprend et qu'on ne se contrôle pas
soi-même
c'est pas possible
donc
pour reprendre l'exemple de l'alcool par
exemple
est-ce que peut-être on pourrait
envisager l'idée que dans un premier
temps
on est on se met à boire plus que de
raison parce qu'on est enivrée non pas
par l'alcool mais plutôt par une vraie
ce que c'est de vivre notre vie sans
inhibition
l'un des premiers leviers du coup pour
ne pas basculer dans l'alcoolisme ne
serait-il pas d'essayer d'accéder à
cette autre partie de notre personnalité
qu'on a maintenant
identifié mais par un autre moyen
peut-être que finalement
pour ne pas devenir addict une des
premières étapes c'est
de se connaître
de se comprendre vraiment de se
connecter à soi-même
sauf que on vit dans un monde compliqué
donc comment est-ce qu'on peut prétendre
faire un vrai travail sur soi si
on est prêt à conditionner à se dire
qu'on est des êtres sans volonté et
qu'on a peut-être peu de discernement et
peu de discipline c'est c'est pas
possible ça marche pas donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait
j'ai quelques idées
la première
c'est la communication
en parler
on va parler à son chien à sa voiture à
son psy un chaman on s'en fiche en fait
en parler
ça c'est vers l'extérieur mais
saviez-vous que la communication
intérieure donc de nous à nous-mêmes et
aussi important si ce n'est plus
important que la communication qu'on a
vers l'extérieur
nous dit même que
notre cerveau fait ce qu'il pense que
l'on veut qu'il fasse
je vous laisse méditer
notre cerveau fait ce qu'il pense que
l'on veut qu'il fasse
elle nous dit aussi la chose suivante
notre cerveau s'est organe n'a
absolument incroyable qui est plein de
rouages absolument impalpable et
finalement aussi complexe qu'il est très
simple
il a pour construire sa vision de notre
réalité deux choses il suffit aux images
que l'on voit dans le monde extérieur et
qu'on projette à l'intérieur de notre
tête et au son au mot donc on entend et
qu'on va se dire à nous-même
c'est donc la qualité de notre dialogue
interne et externe finalement qui
conditionne notre réalité
or comme je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
comment est-ce qu'on peut prétendre
travailler vraiment sur ces pulsions
addictives si on est préalablement
conditionné à se dire que bah on est
juste des êtres qui sommes en train de
pêcher et qu'on a aucune discipline et
aucun discernement ça ne marche pas
ce qui m'amène à mon deuxième point
devenez les castors
construisez et reconstruisez votre
perception de votre environnement et de
votre monde intérieur
je m'explique en fait dès qu'on commence
à creuser un petit peu on se rend vite
compte que la plupart des peurs
qu'on a sont souvent un fondé on se rend
vite compte qu'il y a plein de d'anxiété
qu'on garde et comme contient comme
notre alors que finalement c'est la
société qui les a érigé comme notre et
que en fait c'est pas représentatif de
notre désir en tant que personne
donc
faites-le prenez le temps de
déconstruire et de reconstruire ce que
vous pensez savoir sur votre
environnement franchement je vous assure
c'est un bain de jour
quand j'habitais au Brésil je
vais dans un village où la mer était
souvent dégénérée
et
j'avais très envie de nager vous en
doutez mais
je me suis dit ok si tu veux réussir à
pouvoir braver le courant il faut que tu
t'entraînes tous les jours jusqu'à
développer la force nécessaire pour ne
pas te faire attraper par le courant et
malgré toute ma bonne volonté et tous
mes entraînements
j'ai pas réussi et à chaque fois je me
retrouve sous l'eau et un petit peu
dépité
et
un ami à moi que j'aime vraiment
beaucoup et venu s'asseoir à côté de moi
il m'a dit tu sais je l'ai
c'est normal d'avoir peur de l'océan
celle des fous ne le craignent pas
mais toi tu es folle non pas parce que
tu en as peur parce que tu crois pouvoir
le dominer à la seule force de ton
mental
et
[Musique]
là j'ai compris du coup que
en fait peut-être que finalement il y a
rien à il y a rien à dépasser il y a
tout à accepter j'ai compris qu'en fait
au lieu d'essayer d'apprendre à nager
contre les vagues il fallait que
j'apprenne à nager avec elle
parce que
la vraie liberté je le sais aujourd'hui
c'est pas de dépasser sa pulsion
addictive mais bien de l'accepter
attention accepter n'est pas céder
accepter n'est pas abandonné
accepter c'est agir
parce que on peut pas agir sur une
réalité tant qu'on l'a dit
André Malraux qui est un homme politique
et écrivain français nous dit que la
liberté appartient à ceux qui l'ont
conquise
et finalement
c'est précisément ça
que je vous invite à faire aujourd'hui
à conquérir votre liberté
mais pour faire cela vous allez être
obligé de vous libérer d'abord de la
culpabilité et de la honte
donc
faites le
parce que j'en suis sûr aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment par là qu'il faut passer
je vous souvenez tout à l'heure quand je
vous ai demandé si
vous étiez addict à quelque chose
je vous ai même dit voilà ne vous
inquiétez pas vous n'aurez pas verbalisé
la réponse parce que je sais que cette
question c'est déjà difficile d'y
répondre silencieusement à soi-même mais
c'est encore plus difficile d'y répondre
voilà face à une audience mais vous
savez quoi j'aime beaucoup cette phrase
qui dit
le changement que vous voulez voir dans
le monde
donc
je parle 5 langues couramment j'habite à
Istanbul à Tel-Aviv à Bangkok à Rio à
Sydney j'ai été traductrice rédactrice
wedding planner gérant d'un vignoble
j'ai monté mon entreprise il y a 4 ans
maintenant et il y a quelques années
j'étais SDF fumeuse de Craig dans le
métro à Paris
donc
à cette question finalement que je vous
ai posé moi j'aurais répondu oui
parce que je le serai toujours
mais j'aurais répondu oui sans honte et
sans culpabilité
parce que comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure j'en suis sûr maintenant
en acceptant ma pulsion addictive j'ai
conquis ma liberté
donc gardez-le dans un coin de votre
tête et merci d'avoir écouté